hier hat mir jemand direkt nicht nur
eine sache geschickt sondern gleich zwei
sachen machen wir es mit dem großen
produkt weiter netz geholl dinger großes
produkt brauche ich bin so gespannt was
da drin ist dann weiß ich es wirklich
nicht was geht und herzlich willkommen
zu einem weiteren part den ich
eigentlich jetzt genau nach dem ersten
fahrt aufnehme ich hab mir gerade einen
anderen polio angezogen damit es
wenigstens zu rüberkommt als würde ich
an einem anderen tag aufnehmen
aber jetzt habe ich es eigentlich schon
gesagt das ist nicht so ist aber
eigentlich scheißegal ich mein ich sitze
jetzt zwei stunden drehen ein paar
videos warum nicht leute vielleicht ganz
kurz an die den ersten part nicht
gesehen haben es geht heute um das black
friday opening k2 ich mache ja immer
sehr viele unboxing videos dadurch
bekomme ich extrem viele mails von
irgendwelchen händlern aus aller welt
die mir ihre ganz tollen produkte
andrehen wollen und dann natürlich auch
gerne wollen dass ich für jedes einzelne
produkt so kleines auch ist ein ganzes
video dreh und dafür dann auch gar kein
geld verlangen solche mails krieg sehr
auf und deswegen habe ich viel dann
einfach mal geantwortet und gemeint er
ihr könnt mir selber gerne ein produkt
schicken ich mache dieses black rider
opening ihr könnt ja wahrscheinlich weg
frei machen ja sehr viele händler auf
der ganzen welt mitten ja so entstehen
diese videos wir haben im ersten part
schon drei oder vier produkte ausgepackt
und jetzt machen wir den zweiten part
ich habe mir immer noch 56 sachen liegen
auch große sachen wie man sieht
[Musik]
eine drohne geil ich weiß nicht ob die
100 euro da richtig investiert sind und
eine kampagne für airports mit power und
ach so also wir stecken nicht auf jedem
fall fini was essen wir denn dazu
geschichte dass das hier muss hier noch
auspacken und dass hier was noch
auspacken und dann habe ich da hinten
auch noch was ich weiß nicht aber das
alles in diesem video schaffen sonst
gibt es natürlich auch noch einen
dritten part wenn er dabei aber ich hab
selber drauf weil dann habe ich noch
video mehr daher jeden tag meinst du
einmal telekom okay wäre jetzt genau was
ich mache hier immer werbung für mich ne
manchmal auch zu viel
somit starten ich würde sagen ich habe
gegen die wahl auf das hier ich habe ja
glaub ich hab noch nicht wirklich
reingeguckt das ist immer das problem
wenn ihr morgens irgendwie so ein paket
ankommt ich will aber am liebsten direkt
rein schauen aber ich hab's mir
verkniffen
also dann machen wir das eben jetzt
erstes produkt wir haben hier ich bin
sehr gespannt
[Musik]
ich dachte gerade auf den ersten blick
und nein bitte nicht das nächste
sexspielzeug mal wir hatten im ersten
part als drittes oder viertes produkt
ein sexspielzeug und das ding war
wirklich bedeutung habe ich vorher so
noch nie gesehen im check das auf jeden
fall ab falls das noch nicht gesehen
habe irgendwie jetzt eine reife kamera
ich denke mal es ist eine
überwachungskamera genau moment von
konfiguration
na ja das kann man alles machen aber
sieht das ganze aus von der verpackung
ich habe leider wieder kein kameramann
juli schlechte man ja ok sollte hier mal
ein bisschen platz machen also ich kann
mich daran erinnern
ich habe schon einmal eine
überwachungskamera ausgepackt und zwar
von bush genau für 20 euro oder so und
diese hier macht auf mich jetzt auf
jeden fall schon mal einen
hochwertigeren eindruck
die kann man wahrscheinlich ganz einfach
konfigurieren indem er sich auf dem
handy die app herunterlädt und das dann
mal testet können wir eigentlich machen
oder dazu muss ich nun mal in meinen
händen
leute ich weiß ich sie anders aus auch
andere location
das hat den grund weil ich diesen step
jetzt hier ein bisschen später aufnehmen
ich hab's total vergessen dass sich die
noch testen berichtete scheiß kameras
kamera ist es nicht nadja kamer 42 euro
kostete
dafür stehen geblieben deswegen ich
starb sie mal kurz hier ein also ich hab
mich gerade schon so ein bisschen mit
befasst man kann die halt ganz easy dann
per app mit wlan connecten praktisch
[Musik]
so jetzt haben wir es aber besser ist
aber auch recht lang gedauert und jetzt
starte ich das mal sogar mit sound so
jetzt könnt ihr mich hier sehen
und jetzt kann ich die wahrscheinlich
hier einfach drehen jawohl
warte mal hier die leute jetzt können
jetzt aussehen also ich muss sagen die
qualität ist auf jeden fall meist
deutlich besser als bei diesem wunsch
dingen was ich damals hatte
deswegen kann ich sagen mir gefällt dass
dort nach oben und man kann sogar so ein
bewegungsmelder einstellen und
nachtsicht modus also dass man halt
nachts also dass die nachts auch das
bild klar wiedergeben kann
ja wir wollen dann haben wir das erste
produkt schon hinter uns
ich hab ich gar nicht gesagt diese
sachen auch wie immer ich versuche
allerdings dazu zusammenzustellen und
die euch dann in der video beschreibung
zu verlinken
das heißt wenn euch irgendwas davon
sympathisch rüberkommt im bad ist man
kann sich unterhalten dann könnt ihr
euch das ja gerne erstellen und
meinetwegen diese händler unterstützen
und dann auch in die rezension schreiben
dass ihr von alex kommen damit wir noch
mehr zu stücken machen mal eben hier mit
weiter
das ist ein relativ kleines produkt eine
jacke
man habe ich dann der jackl bestellt
also hier muss ich wirklich sagen ich
kann mich nicht daran erinnern dass sich
bei irgendeinem händler an der jacke
gesehen habe dass denn der jacke
andrehen wollte kommt auf jeden fall aus
china made in china
ihr könnt auch gleich mal daran riechen
man kann es auch meinte er ich muss da
kommt manchmal ist es dort eine jacke
nee das ist eine hose das ist eine große
sache jetzt recht nicht bestellt naja
wahrscheinlich habe ich irgendwo
bestellt und kann mich einfach noch
nicht mehr daran erinnern ich wünsche
mir jetzt wirklich sehr gerne so richtig
anziehen kann ich aber nicht weil das
problem ist ich habe keine unterhose
unter meiner kuriose weil
alter ja also ich muss sagen ist ein
bisschen zu klein ein bisschen wert zu
klein wenn ich mir hosen bestelle
bestelle ich dir eigentlich meistens
sind bei losen oberteilen immer es ist
halt irgendwie so bei mir eventuell
liegt sarah und ich muss ja dann meine
größe weitere geleitet habe oder die
haben einfach ebene größe ausgesucht und
wenn ihr mal aus china kommt da sind die
menschen hier durch sprich
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen kleiner als
hier
dass es dann so halt so klein wird aber
an sich eine nette rose
danke von wem auch immer das kommt nur
ein bisschen klein qualität ist in
ordnung also ich hab schon deutlich
deutlich schlimmer ausgesehen und jahr
fühlt sich ganz gut an nur vom stopp
wert ist also einen johnny muss unter
sondern vom stoff her wie seine
regenjacke genau dann machen wir mal
weiter beraten wo mit machen wir weiter
hiermit oder hier ich will hier mit
weiteren das ziel dass ich hier noch
stehen gegen dies alles schon aus aber
ich kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern
wann ich hier rein geschaut habe
deswegen machen wir es jetzt hier hat
mir jemand direkt nicht nur eine sache
geschickt sondern gleich zwei sachen
haben wir mal mit der kleineren an hh
wir haben die nächste ok also ich mir
jahrhundert stammenden wir haben die
nächste überwachungskamera dieses mal
ist es die xc 6c hier oben könnt ihr
sehen die filme nur in 720p die die wir
eben hatten film sogar 1080p
ich kann eigentlich auch hier mal im
nachschuss mit hardy ist weil die eben
hat ja 42 euro kostet ok hab mal
nachgeschaut kostet bei amazon 30 euro
also an sich 30 euro ist also damals
auch ruhig hbo 20 bezahlt für das dingen
oder fünfzehn oder so ich weiß nicht
mehr genau
und deswegen gehe ich jetzt mal davon
aus das ist absolut ausreichend als
überwachungskamera also ich war auch
damals mit der von höchst zufrieden
diese überwachung scams sie sind
irgendwie alle nicht so teuer und von
der leistung her alle akzeptabel
deswegen sage ich hier einfach mal an
mir wir schauen wenigstens mal kurz rein
bevor ich hier das zweite produkt
auspacken kann man hier stehen gleich so
20.000 überwachungskamera
man darf oder das ist die andere die wir
eben hatten und jetzt habe ich gerade
alter lebt hier vielmehr um eine
airports runtergefahren
so leute hier liegt so viel papier um
alles voller kartons und voll mit diesem
stoff papier
naja ok genau und das ist dann auch
schon das nächste modell
hier haben wir auch wieder nur 720p
der war allerdings so freundlich und hat
mir gleich zwei geschickt einige proben
sie unter die decke zu montieren die
hänge ich mir erst mal hier unten vorbei
konnte kann ich leute beobachten dann
macht auch keine klingel streich mit
antenne also ich würde sagen das ist bis
jetzt auf jeden fall die hochwertigste
ich schaue mal ob was die kostet erzählt
eq 3 w
naja gut auch nicht so viel mehr spaß zu
35 euro bei amazon das sind aber auch
alles komplizierte namen der cdu 3w muss
auch erstmal drauf kommen
ich würd sagen lässt sich jetzt nicht
weil ich will ja nicht das ganze video
über überwachungskameras testen deswegen
machen wir weiter und zwar machen wir es
mit dem großen produkt weiter ja metzger
dinger großes produkt brauche ich bin so
gespannt was da drin ist da weiß ich
wirklich nicht wer jetzt den mega sale
sondern irgendwie so etwas langweiliges
zumindest so ab in die mitte mit dir
alter ein riesending
wir haben hier den ultimativen dennree
robotik vacuum klima und dann ganz dick
drunter made in china deute auf jeden
fall mega fertiges produkt
okay okay jetzt sehe ich schon wieder so
anders aus wie eben also das video
entsteht also praktisch an zwei
verschiedenen orten
wir haben jetzt hier noch diesen sommer
wird auf den ich in köln nicht mehr
geschafft hat auszupacken weil meine
speicherkarte und so voll war dann wenn
japan haben wir hatten schon zwei uhr
deswegen machen wir das jetzt eine
schere wenig mehr war schon eine schere
wenn es auch ohne geht und kann mal raus
also ich habe selber einen saugroboter
in köln von sony falls ich das jetzt
richtig ausgesprochen habe und hier
haben wir jetzt einen von den key
ich glaube den namen habe ich eben auch
falsch ausgesprochen was steht mir drauf
world mit wifi intelligent cleaning ich
weiß nicht ob danach im chaos prinzip
reinigt oder nicht das werden wir noch
rausfinden
und was das noch hier soll ein super
strong ja aber wahr
ich glaube dass dingen kostet 200 euro
oder 220 euro muss ich gleich noch mal
rausfinden
ich bin gerade am überlegen ob ich das
um dieses wieder noch packe oder dann
tatsächlich weil ich habe noch zwei
weitere pakete die drei sogar ob ich
dann noch einen dritten part mache und
ich glaube das mache ich auch deswegen
also dieses ding werde ich vermutlich
dann auch im nächsten party verlosen
schaut euch den an und im nächsten paar
testen wir das dann natürlich auch ich
hoffe ihr seid mir nicht böse wenn ich
das jetzt nicht mache weil das video ist
wahrscheinlich schon wieder viel oder
schon deutlich länger als meine anderen
videos wir sind es dann am freitag um 20
uhr wieder checks auf jeden fall ab ich
weiß in den anderen beiden paketen ist
auch noch cooles zeug drin deswegen wir
sind zwei tage abonniert den kanal
wir haben bald die millionen es werden
immer mehr und vielleicht hat man das
noch dieses jahr würde mich sehr darüber
freuen
3 absolut auf instagram habe ich die
ganzen sache
jetzt in meiner story drin deswegen
check instagram ab und antwortet auf die
story wenn ihr da von irgendwas haben
wollen